The joe rogan experience coder and a,
they wouldn't have done it.
I would not have come back.
I've never been,
Hendricks was on something.
Does that question.
I don't have the evidence and we'll never have it.
Like you don't have the oven incident.
We talked about fighters like that got cut.
You don't have the evidence they were there before it got cut.
Like I don't have the evidence.
The only thing I can say is I didn't want to attack one particular individual
and I wanted to change the system because if you have one individual,
another one would come.
So in that particular case it was Hendrickson and I want it to change it.
And in the beginning he agreed with me to do it,
but then he changed his mind and that's when I got very angry.
Agreed with you to take we,
I agreed.
I agree that it was public.
He agreed.
When we say you can look,
you have the evidence that in the interview he said he agreed to do a test,
but then he said,
uh,
no.
I did not agree.
Because also the UFC told him to not agri that UFC told him the UFC told him is
the truth.
They told him to not do it because I they weren't,
they didn't want,
they had a problem maybe with the um,
at the Vad Vat,
the VAT Aveda world anti-doping
wider that make the guideline but there are [inaudible] that's bad that I took.
They had a problem with them.
I don't know why it wasn't to Conti.
Did he know he was Marimekko rep the go read something or it was a lady but they
had a problem so they said to not do with the desk,
Ma not do it,
period.
I don't know if it was because I think it was because of [inaudible] because I
made that little investigation on that and I got very angry.
That's why like psychologically I said to myself as I shouldn't,
I should not have,
if I would have go back in time,
I would have,
I would not have pegged that,
that fight and when not to think that's fine.
That's why I respect a lot of fight or they stand up for themselves.
I didn't have the courage that I,
I didn't do it when it was time to do it.
And I showed that I regret it about this one thing.
I regretted my career,
I should have done it.
I said,
you don't want to sign,
okay,
take your belt.
I'm going,
yeah,
I should have done that before.
Maybe I would have come back earlier.
Hmm.
So I would miss a paycheck,
but who you know had enough,
I would have enough.
You know what I mean?
So you don't want to say whether or not you suspect that Johnny Hendricks was
doing something,
but there was people that were definitely doing something.
Yes.
I don't have the evidence.
Maybe he did.
Maybe I don't want to accuse.
And I a lot of guide,
they do it and I don't,
I don't want to judge them because I love that they have a family to feed and
everything.
And this could make the difference between winning $1 million or not winning and
like,
Eh,
at all.
You know what I mean?
So everybody has a different reason.
Why are they the,
they do it and I,
and it's just a system and courageous to do with that has that problem.
Yeah.
And especially if there's no testing or the testing is very pools,
like the testing when you first started your career,
I mean basically just had to pee after the weigh in and you were okay.
You have to be,
even now,
it's still easy to,
to even now it's,
yeah man,
it is like how would someone rig the 60 now?
Okay,
let's say you have a,
we're about at my phone.
Okay.
No,
I'm saying it then everybody knows that.
Especially that she thought,
I didn't know that look after I thought it true.
It's not 100% sure,
but let's say I want to have an injection of a product that will last and my
buddy for two days or one day.
So I know that particular day I cannot be tested because if I am,
I'm screwed.
So I put the,
I put my tea,
my worry about that.
I'm traveling to the Freakin Antarctica,
Antarctica or anywhere like somewhere that is crazy.
Leave a bowl and then I come back and do two days after.
But that's obsessed with thin my buddy for a certain period of time,
but it will,
they effect of it will last maybe a month.
And now we talk about performance enhancing drugs.
Joe,
people don't miss on this is there,
well yeah,
but it still doesn't make different.
Yes,
it does make the difference.
And then athlete and the reason is in the 80s and before it was giving you more
power and more stem in a more enjoyments.
Now a man would,
that technology,
they have stuff that will change your reaction time,
your confidence,
your reset time and not,
this is a huge,
huge application man.
If you're,
if you're play baseball or union fighting,
you see the things coming.
You have your reaction time,
your sharper in dead brain.
What makes that Guy Athletic?
It's not as muscle.
The reason why you were saying both is you run faster.
There's many reasons why,
but one of the main reason is because his brain,
his nervous system is better.
And if you make your nervous system better and more competent,
a better,
you're a better athlete,
man,
you'd better fighter a better baseball player.
You better you better person,
better person in a way.
Of course that effect is limited,
but there's still the the muscle memory thing that will last,
you know,
and you could laugh forever.
So now with that technology man at one point the sport,
that's why I'm afraid I'm afraid to sport becomes so messed up that with the
gene doping and all that,
I want to point it would be off sport would be completely,
completely messed up in the future.
I talk not now,
but sport will be,
it won't be any normal people competing will be only like kind of a seaboard.
People,
cyborgs,
everybody.
People are really worried about gene doping and the mentor already starting to
do that.
But on the gene,
even the mother,
the mother and stuff,
performance enhancing drug de Doo man,
it's very hard to catch up people.
So,
like I said,
it's easy to take something.
I mean,
there's always that chance that you get cut,
but that's how I,
if I would do it,
that's how I would do.
I would break down,
I'm going to now Antartica get an injection,
then I come back and I'm,
I'm good.
No.
Wicki told me that there are starting,
will they,
they have it and they don't know whether or not people are taking it,
but they're taking testosterone's is derived from animals,
not from wild yams,
like the way they get testosterone.
Now if you get like a testosterone injection,
they're getting it from a wild yams and some yams.
Yeah.
The fruit of the,
the,
you know,
the vegetable,
the tuber in Jamaica is they,
yeah.
Yeah.
That's how they're getting testosterone.
They're getting it from that
plant based,
um,
wild Yam testosterone.
But now,
uh,
they're able to get it from animals and the animal testosterone,
you,
you don't like,
they do carbon isotope tests and the carbon isotope,
Taz don't detect the difference between a animal testosterone in human
testosterone,
but there's a current tests.
One of the things that they do is they freeze your piss and they freeze your
blood for they're doing it for years and this is how they've caught some of
these Russian wrestlers and they've taken away gold metals from guys at one in
the early two thousands for a,
they found new tests and with the new test they'd be able to determine that they
were taking stereotypies that same thing when Ben Johnson beat Carl Lewis.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
And Ben Johnson this,
well,
he was on some shit,
but guess what?
Carl was not some shit.
Yeah.
Then I think nine out of the 10 or eight out of that,
like the guy that that finished like eight,
like it was a Brazilian guy.
He would eat it.
Any enter you got interviews at?
Yeah.
It was just a fillers for the main guy.
He would have won that gold medal.
Right.
Because man,
that shit changed your life,
man.
That changed your life,
Make you a better living.
Millionaire may be sponsorship that just so bad,
you know?
See?
Yeah man,
this is crazy.
How about Lance Armstrong?
I mean when you go the Tour de France,
when he won and then they took his title away,
all the people that were below him,
we're also guilty.
So you'd take his title away.
What about the number two?
He's fucking guilty too.
Number three,
they said that on one of the years that he won,
you had to go back to 18th place to find a guy who's never caught taking
anything.
That's a dirty sport.
But man,
you asked me if I think he was taking,
I don't know.
I haven't asked.
Suspicions have suspicion,
but it's not right.
If you know what that would,
the evidence to Iq someone.
Yes,
I agree.
And even today it's,
if I think there was some guys,
if there is a lot of guy that takes the red and performance enhancing drug,
yes,
yes.
And I have an idea of who,
and I'm pretty like just for my gut feeling,
99.9% sure.
But I don't want to have the evidence.
It's not what you think.
Some way,
you know,
is where you can prove.
And I,
I don't know.
Yeah.
Talking to,
you know,
I'm in the game,
I'm talking to a lot of people in between fighters.
We know who does,
who.
There's only a few and full of people who does the old,
the whole team.
You know,
one guy could do these steam,
the steam,
the steam and one other guy can do two team.
The word guy that goes around them,
especially when you're,
you're top elite fighters world goes I,
the word goes around,
you know,
like,
like the people,
they,
they talk to me and they say if I,
if I would be interested,
I'd been off different offered before in different things,
you know,
what have you been offered before?
I've been offered men too sometime too to go train and then like some deals,
you know,
like good go train and do,
do,
do something.
Being being part of a,
you know,
like they have a,
they take sample of your blood.
They know what is missing.
Then they put the stuff that is missing.
Make Cube.
As I know,
as I write,
I stay in Montreal.
You know,
like I like I,
and I don't say much Montrell could I,
it could be a lot of cheater too,
right?
Like I,
that's the thing.
You accuse a gym of cheating.
You can actually use a gym of cheating because everybody is different.
You know,
there's people cheating everywhere now you can't say,
oh this,
these people are shit now man,
they,
it doesn't work like that.
It works.
Every individual,
you know,
if you made the choice,
if you decide to go that path,
you have to be ready to face the consequences.
If you don't face a consequence Zirena or your competition years and maybe
you'll face later after you're gone and you retire for your career.
As I,
a lot of a lot of people I know is creating a lot.
Some of my friend,
they were bodybuilders now the seed,
see their buddy are mess up,
man.
There are are all messed up date.
They,
they,
they got bad problem.
I don't want to be like that,
you know,
I don't want to be like that.
I want to be happy.
You know,
I want to be healthy.
Yeah.
They tear the joint apart too.
That's a,
like I had,
um,
Dorian Yates on the podcast.
He can't even do pushups now.
And Dorian Yates was Mister Olympia.
It was a fucking giant guy.
But all that,
everything just ripped apart.
It's like everything's all fucked up.
It just doesn't work right anymore.
However,
if you ask these people,
would you do it again?
Maybe they say,
yeah,
maybe it was worst.
It maybe it was worth it.
Maybe it wasn't.
I think it depends on every individual,
you know what I mean?
But for me,
I'm happy with what I have so far.
I know I could get more,
maybe the future,
but I don't want to do,
to go that path to try to risk everything or what do you want to think when
testosterone replacement therapy was a thing and they were allowing people like
[inaudible] and these people who take testosterone as so freaking angry about
this.
Yeah.
I think it was like,
you know,
I,
everybody,
it's a different case for everybody,
but I believe if you,
if you need to take the medication to compete performance and medication to
compete,
you shouldn't be allowed.
And,
and,
and Joe,
I'm not against the thyroid.
I'm going to explain it to like,
people say,
oh,
he's,
I guess I'm not against Purr,
like stay steroid,
eh,
or Tessa.
I'm not against it.
If it's for their wellbeing,
if it's an older man who we cannot have sex with his wife and he is like,
man that you go see the doctor.
I said,
man,
I,
I lose the edge at it a bit.
Can we do doctor was a,
yeah,
I put the cream that that will increase her.
So you and the guy,
he's happier.
You have sex with his wife.
Competition,
yes.
In terms of competition,
if me and you were fighting and I,
we sign that we're not using any weapon and I'm talking about biological weapon
and we'll fight men to men as a real martial artists by a to of a code of honor.
And you will be.
I know for me,
I go and inject myself something to make me stronger or more competent.
My could also help my neurone tougher to fire,
better to get something to be more,
to be better,
to enhance my performance.
Now,
now I'm against that.
This is a code of honor and the,
if you don't respect that code man,
he should be out of martial arts.
What are people taking that makes the reaction time better?
It makes her mind,
I don't know that the name,
but there there is many.
If you talk to us a guide,
there's a lot of things,
a lot of things.
I know if baseball player,
they take stuff for the reaction time,
like the picture because in baseball and tennis and even in fighting before your
up punch there is like an indication here,
but the buddy language,
he reads something like before you throw a ball there's a movement for you
punched her as well,
so you see better you your brain.
There's even a medication you can take for exam.
You study in school,
there's an exam,
you have an exam tomorrow you're going to study or your,
your desktop that you need to know.
Then at night you will increase you.
Then you go pass the exam.
I know it sound crazy to go.
Go,
go get it.
And it's crazy man.
Well I know Adderall,
Adderall,
swans,
it may I say is man,
you make your bed better in the brain.
If you make your brain better,
your nervous system better man.
You bet you you're a better fighter.
It's not only physic,
physical,
uh,
enhancement.
It wasn't the 80s.
Now when the 2000 year now,
now it's neurologic man.
That's when it's crazy dangerous and so new it will be like it would the gene
doping,
forget it man.
The athlete will be born athlete.
You want me,
I got like me or anybody that fight in UFC won't be able to compete and you have
seen it anymore because they are not super humane human.
You know what I mean?
No,
I agree.
That's what your sport will be so messed up.
It will be crazy.
We're all going to be gamers.
Play video game.
Yeah.
Right.
You're probably right.
We're not going to be gamers.
They're this,
this will be m this thing that like being an athlete,
will it,
it's not gonna make any sense in the future,
I believe in,
or maybe it will be completely ridiculous.
It's like,
oh,
you're not born.
You're never going to be,
you have no choice.
You know what I mean?
And it will be real because you're not born to be an athlete.
You're not bred to be an adult.
Yeah.
They,
with gene editing with their,
they're going to be able to change your height.
They're going,
they can do it now.
They can do it now.
They haven't really shown that they can do it with humans in America,
at least.
Crazy.
But they're absolutely experiencing are experimenting with it all over the
world,
the cow and every like.
It's insane.
They're doing a lot of crazy shit.
Yeah.
And I think maybe it's a hundred years,
maybe it's 50 years,
but whatever it is,
in that amount of time,
you're going to be dealing with people that are basically superheroes.
Yeah.
Sport will be destroyed.
That's why when,
when that happen,
sport will be destroyed.
Yeah,
no,
I agree with spark.
We'll be finish like the 100 meter.
Can you believe that?
Freaking faster human being can be to be closer to zero second.
Yeah.
Do you think would pass the bar of nine second one day?
It's terrible.
Are radically not impossible in a way in like,
I mean I won't point there.
There's a line that you can't like,
you can't diminish that time,
but it's like a of is,
you know like you can't,
you know,
but if we got that sort of performance and ensuing drug decks would be,
but there'll probably be some sort of a side effect to it and some sort of a
downside to it,
then you know,
they'd probably die younger.
Their tissue will diminish faster.
But who knows?
Maybe they'll be able to regenerate stuff if he,
if you talk to some doctor that knows,
I know you have done,
they said that steroid like it performance enhancing drug if you do it,
if they do it well,
it's okay.
Some people don't have any side effect of it.
Right.
They don't abuse it.
Yes.
Yeah.
So man,
maybe it won't have any side effect.
Maybe everybody will be on it.
Maybe it would be like a,
like a iPhone will be like,
oh,
that's like,
who knows?
Who knows the future?
Who knows?
You know?
Okay.